i was very very bookish i was reading
all the time so i was either reading
uh working on my computer reading comics
playing dungeon dragons
that kind of thing you are first and
foremost
a spiritual being having a human
experience
companies are learning organisms and
you can make decisions that either make
it so that you learn faster
or you learn slower wanna be happy build
a life
not just a business
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back
a lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you know there's
something more inside you
you've got michael jordan level talent
at something so today let's live your
best believe life and learn the seven
best lessons from elon musk and other
billionaires
enjoy
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one read books with elon musk
i certainly was quite i was very very
bookish i was reading all the time
so i was either reading working on my
computer
reading comics playing dungeon dragons
that kind of thing
i understand hitchhiker's guide to the
galaxy that wonderful book by douglas
adams that was a
that was a key book for you what was it
about that book that
that fired your imagination um yeah so
uh i guess when i was in the around
12 or 13 i had company existential
crisis and i was reading various books
on trying to figure out the meaning of
life and well like what does it all mean
because
uh it starts seeming quite meaningless
and then
um uh my we happen to have like some
some books by nietzsche and schopenhauer
in the house
which you should not read at age 14 is
bad
it's really negative um
so so uh but then i read hitchhiker's
guide to the galaxy it was
like quite positive i think and um
and it sort of highlighted the the an
important point which is
that a lot of times the question is
harder than the answer and if you can
properly phrase the question
then the answer is the easy part and so
uh
the if to agree that we can um better
uh understand the universe then we
better know what questions to ask
and um then whatever the question is
that most approx
approximates what's the meaning of life
you know that that's that's the question
we could ultimately
get closer to understanding um
and so i thought well to agree that we
can expand the
scope and scale of consciousness and
knowledge um human knowledge then
that would be a good thing rule number
two cultivate a spiritual life with
oprah winfrey
i teach them that there is no life
without
cultivating a spiritual life because you
are
first and foremost a spiritual being
having a human experience and if you
lose sight of that
it's easy to get lost in the world and
no one can save a world that they're
lost in
when they've lost sight of their own
north star so having a spiritual life
actually means actively and ritually
creating the space in your life all the
time
for gratitude for kindness for empathy
for inspiration for joy and for
reverence for life
in the home of your soul first
and then working to spread that inner
joy
outward it means slowing down
it means taking in the moment it means
being exactly
where you are not distracted
somewhere else it means knowing who you
are
and getting about the business of
fulfilling
why you really came to our planet
rule number three never give up with
jack ma
the only thing is that um as an
entrepreneur
that never you know build up a good team
and set the the a big vision
but mile stones and you know go
go on never give up you might have a lot
of problems
right you can see the problem you're
facing your competitor will face it too
yeah and you think you have a lot of
tough days but you're competitively
having much easier
you never know right so so you say that
the competition between you is not a com
is is the speed of solving the problems
also if you want to have more self-love
confidence and learn from billionaires
check out my 254 series they're free
the links to join are in the description
below ideas don't come out
fully formed they only become clear
as you work on them you just have to get
started
if everything has to work in two to
three years
then that limits what you can do i've
always been passionate
some people thought you know it's more
ocd than anything else
rule number six find your gift with mark
cuban
companies are learning organisms and
you can make decisions that either make
it so that you learn faster
or you learn slower and you know in a
lot of ways building a company is like
following the scientific method right
you try a bunch of different hypotheses
and if you set up the experiments well
then you kind of learn what to do
and again that's that's an important
philosophy so
there are all these different decisions
that we make inside the company you know
everything down to
um really empowering individual
engineers we invest in this huge
testing framework right at any given
point in time there aren't there's not
just one version of facebook running in
the world right there's
probably tens of thousands of versions
running because engineers here have the
power
to um to try out an idea and
and and ship it to you know maybe ten
thousand people or a hundred thousand
people
and then they get a readout on how uh
that version of what they did whether it
was
um a change to you know show better
content a news feed or
ui change or some new feature they get a
readout on how
uh that version performed compared to
the baseline version of facebook that we
have on everything that we care about
how
how connected people are um you know how
much people are sharing and how much
they
say that they're finding meaningful
content uh business metrics like how
much revenue we make and engagement of
the overall community
and you know by running tens of
thousands of different
experiments and putting the power in
people's hands to try all these
different things
you can imagine we just make so much
more progress than we could if every
change had to be approved by me
right or any every idea had to come from
from management so
i do think there's something very deep
about building this
you know learning culture and moving
quickly towards that that
just helps you get ahead over time rule
number four
experiment with mark zuckerberg one of
the precursors one of the foundational
things
to being able to take risk is to have
had some kind of support from somebody
you have to have some mentors
you have to have somebody who loves you
these are the kind of things that build
up and allow you
to kind of you know jump off into
uncharted terrain and do something new
because you know you have
a support system of one kind or another
and
and i certainly did so for me i just
want to point out that i've
i i feel very strongly that um
there's a lot i've won a lot of
lotteries uh amazon is one of the
lotteries that i've won
but i had a big lottery with my parents
my dad is a cuban immigrant
he came here when he was 16 years old
didn't speak any english
my his is a great guy and my
mother had her had me when she was 17
years old
so she was a pregnant 16 year old in
albuquerque new mexico in high school
which was not cool
and she made it work and her her parents
my grandparents helped her with that
whole thing and
made made that all work and if you don't
get that kind of
support somehow it doesn't have to be
your parents sometimes people get lucky
it's a grandparent or it's a friend or a
family friend or a teacher
it can be somebody but you need that
somebody has to step into your life
and that's a lottery that i suspect a
lot of people in this room have also won
just like me rule number five find
supportive people with jeff bezos
my dad busted his ass i mean he worked
six
six days a week left at seven
at seven seven thirty in the morning got
back at six or seven o'clock
um lost his eye in an accident doing
upholstery he had a staple break when he
was putting
um um some
covering on a car seat um you know
it was it was a middle-class upbringing
my mom did
odd jobs you know they they just wanted
something better i mean my grandparents
came over from russia and
you know my dad was the first generation
my uncles were the first generation
americans like my mom too and you know
like
every child of immigrants they wanted
better for their kids you know it's
funny
i mean a lot of people grow up that way
right but not many people end up like
you so
what do you think that's the result of i
think
you know everybody's got something that
they're good at
and the hard part is just finding it and
i found out early that i was a good
salesperson that i really liked business
you know like i like sports i mean i
read everything i possibly could played
sports as much as i could
just wasn't as good as i wanted to be
and and business was the same way i mean
as long as i could remember
i was buying and selling baseball cards
garbage bags
whatever i could find stamps um to
collectors
but i was also reading everything i
possibly could about business and
you know i was that unusual kid that i'd
rather read
about ted turner than go to the movies
and and so i think that
created a foundation of my parents you
know my dad used to always say i don't
understand what you're doing
but i'm glad you're doing it and and so
i had my ups and downs along the way of
course but um
i just think that i just i just put in
the time and
was fortunate enough to really get
excited about business and that paid off
benefits over the long haul
and rule number seven the last one
before very special bonus clip
is take control of your life with sarah
blakely
a lot of people think that spanx started
when i cut the feet out of my pantyhose
but actually it started long before that
it started when i was selling fax
machines door-to-door
and getting my car business card ripped
up in my face being escorted out of
buildings
all day every day that i woke up one day
and just thought
i'm in the wrong movie like how did this
happen this is not my life
cut scene director like call the
producer
and i got out a piece of paper and i
wrote down what am i good at
and the only thing in the good column
was sales and i thought okay what am i
going to do with that and i ended up
writing in my journal i'm going to
invent a product and sell it to millions
of people
that will make them feel good and then i
asked the universe for an
idea and i was very specific and it took
two years
and i only cut the feet out of my
pantyhose one time and i was not going
to squander any idea the universe gave
me because i had really asked for it
and then the minute i cut the feet out i
started trying to make it
i started looking up manufacturers on
the internet this is before
alibaba wasn't it yes now i have a
special bonus clip from john paul de
gioria on how to be
positive that i think you're going to
enjoy but before that it's time for the
question today i want to know where do
you need to take
control of your life let me know put it
down the comments below and if you made
it this far in a video you're still here
watching i want to celebrate you because
believe nation we don't just watch
videos we
do something about it so that's you and
you commit you promise you're going to
take action
immediately after watching this video
give me a hashtag believe down in the
comments and tell me where you're from
because i want to celebrate you so of
all the things in the world that you
could say are like the secrets
that being positive is one of the main
things that people need to do
how did you happen on that in life
whether it's personal or people around
me
when you see people that are positive
that look at something good and
something bad that took place
they move along in life faster they're
better and people want to be around
these people
i mean too often people gossip the one
gossip person wants to be around the
other person that gossips
but they don't realize when you gossip
you're saying something you heard about
somebody else
you're telling everybody what if part of
it was wrong you're gonna go out and
tell every person you told this oh
i'm sorry it was wrong tell everybody
you told it's not gonna happen
so it's things you learn about don't
gossip don't build little people if you
don't have to god please don't
try and look at the positive angle what
good could come out of something
and that positiveness is going to make
you live longer
happier and wake up in the morning happy
not oh my god i got to go to work i
can't wait till i get home i want to
retire
because people were not positive they
were not happy and what happens if they
retire
they hate their job they retire three or
four years later they're dead because
they have nothing to do
that positive attitude be around
positive people
encourage positiveness if you find
yourself walking around just complaining
all the time around people that complain
a lot
man move or just try and do something
different change your life
being positive and a positive attitude
is find something positive and something
bad makes you look for
solutions when i was down and out okay
oh pop bottles let's get the pop bottles
cash them in
[Music]
if you want to learn seven more lessons
from billionaires check out the video
right there next to me i think you'll
enjoy it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there i don't fear anything but i worry
about everything
and the day you stop worrying in good
times
the paddle will get you behind